pensant mesdemoiselles et bonsoir
messieurs non à tout le monde en général
et pour quoi tu parle doucement aux cas
les plus forts ensemble des français
messieurs me dis donc qu'est ce que tu
vas là non oui tu es malade
non je suis marqué garde émission domino
taux supportables et 10 des antilles
c'est ce que j'ai dit non je vais te
dire je suis candidat aux élections
présidentielles
tu te présentes nestor président
français françaises cotées nestor et si
je suis élu une cocotte en chocolat pour
tout le monde tous les dimanches
et qui a là aussi j'ai printemps tandis
que saint cyr culture est né un pic à
l'aviculture sobrement l'agriculture
tient chaud cet effet épouse mais tu
crois que tout le monde va voter pour
toi est ce que tu connais quelqu'un qui
va voter pour toi
ah oui c'est vrai quelqu'un qui va
vraiment voter pour toi ah oui mais qui
mois coûte en attendant j'ai juré de
mettre au lit mais ce qu'on sera les
premiers clichés de nos